it seems like blondes do have more fun
in Selena Gomez's case she's enjoying
mixing up her fashion Selena's sick of
that same old outfit and et has the
style breakdown on Monday the wolf
singer switched things up for her promo
tour in London pulling off for trendy
looks in one morning I'm gonna change a
lot 25 year old Selena dressed to
impress at her first stop rocking a
floral printed Isabel Murad dress paired
with bright red Mansoor Gabriel flats
then she headed over to BBC Radio 1 and
a black Proenza Schouler dress with a
white long-sleeve shirt underneath
different from anything I've ever done
you know it's a totally different style
the winter weather didn't play a role in
this outfit change next she sported this
off-the-shoulder Navy mini by Koosh neo
docks there was one common accessory for
these ensembles a pair of Torah cat eye
sunglasses from her stylist Kate Young's
collection for her final look of the
press tour Selena went out with a bang
check out the pop star looking coober
chic in a plaid coat designed by Faye
a black Prada miniskirt and the same
statement slides from earlier Selena's
street style continues to be on point
you